bonsoir et bienvenue dans savouregarde
un plateau exceptionnel ce soir pour la
sortie en salle aujourd'hui du film
Simone le voyage du siècle nous recevons
la comédienne Elsa Zilberstein qui
incarne Simone Veil à l'écran et le
réalisateur Olivier Dahan féministe
anti-totalitarisme Europe tous les
combats de Simone Veil vous le verrez
sont d'une brûlante actualité Jean-Louis
Debré l'ancien président de l'assemblée
sera également sur ce plateau
l'assemblée où a été votée la loi veille
en 1975 au terme d'un débat d'une
violence inouïe également en plateau la
députée le droit à l'avortement dans la
Constitution à ne pas manquer donc un
débat spécial à partir de 20 heures dans
la deuxième partie mais avant cela on va
commencer avec l'actualité de la crise
des carburants le mouvement de grève
dans les raffineries ne faiblit pas il
est reconduit partout le gouvernement
passe à la méthode forte et dégaine les
réquisitions alors pourquoi une telle
prise de risque quelles conséquences la
taxation sur les super profits à
l'Assemblée nationale peut-elle calmer
la grogne que ça fasse tout de suite
entre deux députés David Agnel pour la
majorité et manuel Bompard pour la
France insoumise voilà pour le menu ce
soir c'est parti
[Musique]
1/3 des stations services touchées par
les pénuries et une galère sans nom pour
les automobilistes la crise des
carburants ne faiblit pas bien au
contraire le mouvement de graisse
s'intensifie avec la décision du
gouvernement de réquisitionner les
personnels grévistes notamment dans la
raffinerie des sceaux-exxon mobile port
Jérôme Gravenchon c'est en scène
maritime bonsoir David Daniel bonsoir et
merci beaucoup d'être sur ce plateau
député renaissance de Paris vous
débattez si j'ose dire une fois de plus
avec votre collègue de la France
insoumise manuel Bompard bonsoir député
insoumis des Bouches-du-Rhône alors vous
avez tous les deux pilotés une mission
flash sur la taxation des super profits
à l'Assemblée nationale elle a rendu ses
conclusions il y a quelques jours
quelques à peine une grosse semaine
evidemment le sujet il est lié à la
crise des carburants on va y venir mais
on va commencer avec le biais de lako
pour nous planter le décor si j'ose dire
de ces grèves si j'ai bien compris
Stéphane lakowski tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
messieurs bonsoir si j'ai bien compris
ce soir alors si j'ai bien compris
Myriam la CGT aimerait bien le bloquer
le pays en organisant des grèves dans
les raffineries bon à vrai dire pour un
Français de 54 ans comme votre serviteur
soit vraiment un truc surprenant on la
connaît notre bonne vieille CGT et si on
l'apprécie alors je dis si on l'apprécie
on n'est pas obligé de l'apprécier mais
si on apprécie c'est souvent parce que
justement elle n'a pas peur d'engager le
rapport de force et c'est pas nouveau je
vous rappelle que en 2019 il y avait
déjà eu ce blocage des raffineries pour
empêcher la réformer les retraites ce
qu'il y avait d'ailleurs été empêché
mais avant 2016 il y avait eu un
appareil appuyé sur les blocages de
raffinerie cette fois-ci pour empêcher
la loi travail qui avait été voté que
voulez-vous la CGT c'est un syndicat ils
sont comme ça ils aiment bien faire de
la politique alors aujourd'hui ce sont
des augmentations de salaire que les
salariés de séraphineries réclament via
la grève de la CGT
c'est dû dans les syndicats qui sont
majoritaires chez Esso ont tenu une
augmentation de salaire en accord avec
la direction alors ça la CFDT la signé
mais la CGT elle poursuit le mouvement
grec d'ailleurs il y a un syndicaliste
de chef il faut qu'il va nous rejoindre
donc ils sont pas tous seuls et faux
aussi participe et donc Élisabeth borne
voilà ce qu'elle a fait hier elle a ir
décrété à l'Assemblée qu'elle allait
réquisitionner les travailleurs dans les
raffineries d'ailleurs je crois qu'il y
a quelqu'un qui a été enseigne maritime
un ouvrier de raffinerie qui a été
réquisitionné cet après-midi donc fait
le bras de fer mais à la CGT on adore ça
le bras de fer donc une nouvelle
raffinerie s'est mis en grève
aujourd'hui et on finit par se poser la
question est-ce que vraiment la CGT fait
ça pour obtenir des augmentations de
salaire ou elle fait ça parce qu'elle a
envie de déstabiliser le gouvernement je
me souviens que là ils ont lancé une
grève la CGT par exemple dans les
centrales nucléaires bon en tout cas
pour ce qui est d'autres syndicats comme
la CFDT on n'est pas du tout raccord
avec cette manière de faire du
syndicalisme on écoute Laurent Berger
je suis désolé de le dire comme ça mais
je le pense vraiment donc je le dis
quand on est une organisation syndicale
la CGT dans ce secteur là qui décide de
pas vouloir négocier vraiment et qui
décide seulement le rapport de force
sans aller au bout de la logique qui est
de négocier et d'acter un compromis par
un accord bah on est dans cette
situation alors en revanche la CGT a
reçu le soutien de la nupcesseur
mais il faut dire que le total n'a pas
forcément été très à droite de prendre à
témoin le pignon public parce que si
sont les calculs de Total si on
additionne donc le salaire la prime le
13e mois en moyenne un employé de
raffinerie toucherait autour de 5000
euros donc vous sentez bien qu'on
voulait les montrer du doigt ces
employés ce problème c'est que Patrick
Pollionnay bon il a fait Polytechnique
donc il sait compter mais c'est pas le
seul à savoir compter Fabien Roussel il
prend sa calculatrice il sait ses
calculs si on l'écoute on a affaire à un
groupe qui a distribué deux milliards
500 millions d'euros de dividendes
d'exceptionnels au premier semestre 2
milliards 500 millions d'euros on parle
en milliards ça permettrait ces 2
milliards 5 d'augmenter de 300 euros les
35 salariés de Total pendant 12 mois et
sur 12 ans vous vous rendez compte 2
milliards 500 millions d'euros c'est 12
ans d'augmentation de salaire garantie
communiste qui soutient la CGT j'ai
envie de dire c'est classique rien
d'autre de vieux français de 54 ans le
sait bien que c'est à peu près logique
là ce qui surprenant c'est qu'il n'y a
pas que la gauche qui pointe du doigt
les super profil réalisé par Total leur
rassemblement national on est on va dire
exactement sur la même longueur monde
Marine Le Pen avait demandé à ce contact
les pétroliers pendant la campagne au
mois de mars après la réélection de
Emmanuel Macron elle a enfoncé clou
demandant à nouveau à ce qu'on taxe les
pétroliers donc c'est une demande
constante d'ailleurs ce matin Laurent
jacquebellier était sur Public Sénat ce
n'est pas du tout pris à la CGT il a
tapé sur le patron de Total qui s'est
augmenté de 50% cette année donc
forcément voilà peut-être un partage des
richesses ce serait le bienvenu on
l'écoute
on voulait créer une surtax de 25% sur
les surprofistes c'est-à-dire les
profits générés par la crise en Ukraine
ou par l'inflation mais il fallait
probablement aussi réfléchir avec les
salariés bref on a compris ce sont les
superfiques qui sont au cœur de ce débat
quand vous dites bref quand elle dit
bref c'est que il faut que je me dépêche
c'est il est temps de conclure on jouait
vous laisser des battre juste faire une
petite remarque avant une toute petite
remarque vous allez voir vous savez
qu'en ce moment Poutine mène une guerre
de l'énergie et que sa tactique c'est de
tenter de remonter les opinions
européennes contre leur gouvernement
pour déstabiliser nos démocraties donc
je pense que tout le monde est au
courant de ça donc je me demande si
juste c'est vraiment la bonne idée pour
lancer un appel à la grève générale on
écoute Sandrine Rousseau
salarié demande au salon d'entreprise
des augmentations salariales notamment
quand il y a eu des profits assez
importants dans le secteur pétrolier ce
qui insupportable c'est que une fois
qu'un accord a été obtenu et c'est le
cas à Esso Essonne mobile ratifié par
une majorité 5% d'augmentation cet
accord il demande plus dans un contexte
d'inflation à 5 % non les syndicats
majoritaires ont accepté cet accord les
syndicats qui représentent la majorité
des salariés donc ce sont des syndicats
minoritaires qui poursuivent une grève
et donc ce qui est insupportable
aujourd'hui c'est qu'une minorité de
salariés au sein d'une entreprise
ce qui est la voix de la justice et de
l'efficacité tout à la fois d'ailleurs
pour l'ensemble des salariés du pays
c'est la négociation sociale et une fois
qu'un accord a été signé il faut savoir
terminer une grève c'était une citation
de Maurice Thorez d'il y a plus de 80
ans je ne crois pas que c'est soit
quelqu'un de droite ou de
particulièrement libéral le début de la
fin mais alors pour le moment la grève
toujours là je vous donne la parole dans
un instant mais la nouveauté c'est la
décision de réquisition plus ou moins
mise en oeuvre vous avez l'impression
qu'on vous jetez pas de vue sur le feu
avec cette décision mais je crois que
cette décision était très attendue par
tous les Français qui ne parviennent
plus à faire le plein dans toutes les
stations de service que vous citez et
donc on avait besoin à nouveau dans
l'entreprise qui a déjà négocié un
accord avec ses salariés de pouvoir
débloquer la situation pour ne pas
laisser une minorité de salarié au sein
de l'entreprise bloquer la fois toute
l'entreprise et tout le pays manuel
Bompard on peut soutenir un mouvement de
grève tant pis pour les automobilistes
qui galèrent tant pis pour les
aides-soignantes tant pis pour les les
livreurs tous ces Français d'origine
modeste qui font partie souvent de vos
électeurs mais vous savez
que tout le monde soit impacté par cette
situation c'est une évidence personne
ici va ne va le contester on sera tous
d'accord sur le sujet la question est de
savoir qui porte la responsabilité de la
situation de blocage dans laquelle on
est aujourd'hui
franchement quand on voit l'impact sur
la vie quotidienne des Français
bien évidemment ses responsable et c'est
même un devoir de soutenir des
mobilisations quand elles sont justes et
d'ailleurs vous avez cité un sondage
tout à l'heure vous auriez pu citer
l'autre partie du sondage qui dit qu'il
y a davantage de Français qui
soutiennent aujourd'hui les grévistes
que de personnes qui sont contre leur
mobilisation et je ne suis pas le seul à
l'instant je ne suis pas le seul à
soutenir cette mobilisation il y a
grande partie des Français qui l'a
comprend aujourd'hui il y a une décision
et pourtant et pourtant ils ont
subissent les effets dans leur vie au
quotidien mais parce qu'ils ont compris
que cette revendication d'augmentation
de salariale elle est juste et que si on
est dans une situation de blocage
aujourd'hui contrairement à ce que vous
avez dit c'est parce que la direction de
l'entreprise en défilé de Total à refusé
de négocier depuis trois semaines a dit
il y aura pas de négociation salariale
avant le 15 novembre et enfin dis-moi le
dernier parce que j'ai eu de la grève
parce que il y a eu la grève ils ont dit
on veut bien ouvrir les négociations
maintenant ce soir quand même la
décision de réquisitionner la raffinerie
de port Jérôme à si je peux me permettre
de porter ses fruits mais des guillemets
puisque les négociations à Total
reprennent ça veut dire quoi pour vous
ça a marché la méthode Ford David Amiel
mais je crois que c'était une méthode en
tout cas
mais je crois que ce qui est très
important c'est de bien distinguer les
deux entreprises que vous citez chez
Esso et que ça ne mobile il y a eu un
accord qui a été ratifié par une
majorité de salariés de l'entreprise
vaisseau et donc c'est une majorité de
salariés syndicats qui représentent une
majorité des salariés mais je trouve
professionnelle de ya je ne sais pas
combien de temps donc ne dites pas que
c'est la majorité des salariés
si on pense qu'il y a qu'une minorité
moi je vous pose une question si on
pense qu'il y a qu'une minorité de
blocage qui soutient ce mouvement à
aixon pourquoi la raffinerie elle tombe
pas mais parce qu'on sait très bien
qu'il suffit de quelques dizaines de
personnes sur un site et que ce sont que
quelques dizaines qui sont pas d'accord
je les ai pas contrôlés vérifié mais je
pense qu'ils sont bons et c'est les
cheats qu'ils ont donné pour
l'entreprise et SOS maintenant pour
revenir à ce que disait Emmanuel Bompard
je sais qu'il y a une habitude à la nups
qui est toujours contester la légitimité
des élections qu'elle soit politique ou
sociale mais enfin moi je considère
qu'il y a eu des élections dans ces
entreprises là je n'ai pas les remettre
en question il y a des syndicats qui
représentent les services
il ne faut pas toujours s'aligner
pardonnez-moi il faut pas toujours
saigner sur les positions les plus
radicales au sein d'une entreprise elle
exprime effectivement en mode vision de
la démocratie cueillez des syndicats qui
est la dernière élections dans cette
entreprise exson parce qu'après on
pourra parler total qui représente quand
même l'essentiel des raffineries dont on
parle si vous voulez on en parlera après
que dans cette entreprise il y a des
organisations syndicales qui eut la
dernière fois une majorité des
salaristes en fait ça ne fait pas
disparaître pour autant le fait qu'il y
a d'autres organisations syndicales
qu'il y a d'autres salariés et qu'ils
ont des revendications et qu'ils ont
droit de les avoir et que le droit de
grève monsieur contrairement à ce que
vous pensez c'est garanti par la
constitution même quand il y a un accord
majoritaire signé par quelques
entreprises on a le droit de se mettre
en grève et constitutionnel c'est vrai
la galère elle est au quotidien on va
quand même écouter ceux qui traînent
aujourd'hui
une application qui vous dit tel endroit
il y a de l'essence vous arrivez elle
n'est pas ouverte la station donc voilà
on galère depuis ce matin depuis 7h du
matin je suis dans la rue
les applications je cherche je pars hier
soir il y a tenter ma chance et 1h du
matin j'ai pas trouvé et là c'est le
matin pour l'instant tout se passe bien
on verra si on arrive je suis très en
colère et très nerveuse aussi je
comprends la grève je comprends qu'on
veut augmenter les salaires mais ce que
je comprends pas c'est qu'on bloque tout
un pays comme ça il y a des discussions
et vous avez des syndicats aller
discuter et puis battez-vous mais vous
n'êtes pas obligé de bloquer tout un
pays réquisition c'est il faut en
arriver là oui oui
voilà pour ces Paroles de Français
bonsoir Hakim belhouze et merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes délégué syndical
Force Ouvrière pour les raffineries
force ouvrières qui entrent dans la
grève ce soir alors pourquoi maintenant
pourquoi pas avant
en fait avant si vous voulez ça fait 5
ans que qu'on a des soucis direct social
dans cette entreprise on a décidé on
alerté depuis plusieurs mois la
direction totale que il va falloir faire
des choses et puis on n'a jamais été
entendu on a face à une direction qui
est sourde donc on a on n'est pas pour
la grève préventive on privilégie
sociale dans l'entreprise et la
négociation
ça commence à rouvrir la main étendue
pour ouvrir des négociations avec la CGT
alors c'est c'est étonnant de de durcir
le ton maintenant
oui mais c'est terminé ou
merci vous me posez une question donc
nous stratégie c'était de mettre un coup
de semence c'est ce qu'on a fait pendant
72 heures du 27 au 29 septembre ça
c'était une stratégie on s'y tenue
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé derrière on a
arrêté on a stoppé la rêve d'ailleurs il
y a eu des communiqués de Total qui a
acheté ces séries en pâture à la
populaire avec en affichant des salaires
mirobolants enfin je sais pas enfin bref
on nous a été très mal vécu par les
salariés sur tous les sites donc
derrière il y a eu effectivement
également l'intervention du gouvernement
avec la menace de réquisitions c'est bon
on a compris le message il y a pas de
souci donc on a décidé de parler
l'ensemble des le gouvernement il peut
pas nous dire le dimanche il faut être
apaisé il faut être responsable il faut
discuter il faut faire il faut pas faire
et puis deux jours après nous dit on va
vous envoyer des bâtons de CRS pour pour
vous pour vous excusez-moi pour vous
c'est la décision de réquisition qui
vous fait entrer dans le bras de fer si
je comprends bien effectivement la
décision plus et surtout le communiqué
total c'est les deux donc aujourd'hui
nous on assumer faux on vous le dit
Madame on assume on restera dans la
grève tant qu'il se passera pas des
choses concrètes dans notre entreprise
à chaque à chaque décision de
réquisition votre état d'esprit a est
fausse c'est d'aller faire des recours
en justice c'est ça oui effectivement on
a nos avocats qui sont dans les starting
blog qui s'assureront qui s'associeront
pardon excusez-moi aux avocats de la CGT
et on fera on fera valeur nos droits au
bout d'un moment c'est un juge qui va
décider si c'est légal ou si c'est pas
légal nous on pense au bout d'un moment
dans le droit de grève il est vraiment
remis en cause mais c'est pas grave on a
su moi on ira en justice merci beaucoup
merci à Kim bellouse pour voilà ce point
de vue franc de la position de de Force
Ouvrière la voix de passage elle est
extrêmement étroite David Amiel on a
l'impression que voilà on s'attendait
peut-être à une sortie de crise dans les
jours qui viennent si ça se trouve ça va
ça va durer encore toute la semaine on
verra mais vous l'avez dit ce qui est
très important aujourd'hui c'est que
Total et le efficace CGT semble se
mettre autour de la table des
négociations c'est ce qu'on a d'ailleurs
déjà obtenu en début de semaine pour
Esso et je crois que c'est là dedans
qu'il faut continuer à avancer je crois
que c'est vraiment essentiel et je
trouve pour réciter à nouveau le
reportage que vous avez fait en début de
cette émission que d'ailleurs comme
souvent Sandrine Rousseau a dit un peu
tout haut ce qu'une grande partie de la
nups pense tout bas c'est à dire qu'au
fond cette affaire est un prétexte pour
lancer l'étincelle je reprends un peu
les mots qu'elle a prononcé pour
déclencher une grève générale en
s'asseyant au passage sur la démocratie
sociale dans ces entreprises puisqu'une
majorité de salariés s'y oppose et en
s'asseyant évidemment sur les blocages
et les souffrances que ça fait peser sur
tout le pays et particulièrement sur les
plus modestes d'entre eux parce que
c'est pas les plus riches qui prennent
leur voiture tous les jours des dizaines
de kilomètres pour aller travailler
qu'est-ce que vous dites à ce qu'on a
entendu qui sont en colère même si
comprennent que des revendications
est-ce que au fond si totale aujourd'hui
remettait la ristourne prolongeait la
ristourne au-delà de la fin d'année sur
sur le prix à la pompe si les
négociations s'ouvraient avec davantage
d'augmentation de salaire vous leur
dites attendez patientez ça va pas durer
non mais je leur dis je comprends que
vous êtes dans une situation difficile
mais la responsabilité contrairement à
ce qu'on essaye de vous faire croire
c'est pas la responsabilité des salariés
qui sont mis en grève c'est la
responsabilité des directions
d'entreprises qui refusent d'aborder des
négociations salariales qui sont
totalement légitimes on reprend
l'exemple donc en fait vous dites à ces
gens venez à la grande marche contre la
vie chère que je leur dis ça venait dans
tous les cas manifester
je suis en train de vous dire nous nous
trompons pas la responsabilité de la
situation de blocage elle appartient au
groupe en question et au gouvernement
parce que le gouvernement depuis deux
semaines avait la possibilité de taper
du point sur la table et total de
direction maintenant on va se mettre
autour de la table avec les
organisations syndicales et on va
négocier les salaires même monsieur
Macron c'est le Canard Enchaîné ce matin
dit que les revendications des salariés
de ces entreprises sont légitimes même
le président de la République il le
dites la taxation sur les supers profits
70 pour 79 % des Français estiment
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'est pas à la
hauteur dans ce dossier vous
reconnaissez peut-être une forme de déni
au départ
pas du tout je crois pas qu'il y a eu un
déni au départ il y a simplement un
mouvement social qui évolue depuis une
semaine le rôle du gouvernement c'est de
pouvoir appuyer la négociation c'est pas
de s'y substituer et c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a aussi laissé ce temps
au dialogue social ça a permis d'obtenir
des avancées maintenant du côté de la
nuit on considère que aucune avancé
aucune négociation n'est accélérée
dimanche dernier des négociations vous
auriez pu les provoquer je vous dis pas
vous substituer vous auriez pu dire bon
monsieur total vous voulez pas discuter
maintenant discuter avec les
organisations syndicales vous l'avez pas
fait vous avez attendu dimanche que les
pénuries commencent à exister et en même
temps vous dites quand c'est des
résultats de discussion ça ne vaut pas
ça ne vaut rien les élections
professionnelles
ce soir et on l'entend ce qui nous
regardent l'entende les députés bon se
saisir de cette question de la taxe sur
les super profits en plein débats
budgétaires on va faire un petit rappel
des forces politiques en présence sur ce
sur ce dossier assez complexe avec
Clément Méric et je vous repasse la
parole juste après regarder
ne dites surtout pas à Bruno Le Maire
qu'il s'attaque au super profit la
réalité c'est que c'est les rentes
auxquelles nous voulons nous attaquer on
parle de rente ou de super profit dans
les faits les bénéfices de certains
groupes ont bondi sur les six premiers
mois de l'année plus 117% pour engie
plus 190 % pour Total énergie plus 214 %
pour le groupe de transport de fret
maritimes CMA CGM conformément à
l'accord trouvé au niveau européen le
gouvernement prévoit de taxer une partie
de ces bénéfices à hauteur de 33% salle
de concerne que les producteurs de
pétrole de gaz de charbon ou les
raffineurs donc en l'espèce en France
comme il n'y a que du raffinage à ne
concerne que les raffineurs et ça ne va
nous rapporter que 200 millions d'euros
la recette attendue est faible car seuls
les profits réalisés sur le territoire
français peuvent être taxés le groupe
les républicains votera cette
contribution exceptionnelle mais la
droite voudrait l'étendre au fret
maritimes tout comme pérenne qui aurait
voulu y ajouter les sociétés d'autoroute
le gouvernement s'inspire de nous c'est
très bien ce que je déplore c'est qu'on
a perdu trois mois parce qu'on l'a
proposé au mois de juillet et que si le
gouvernement avait été honnête et le
mois de juillet peut-être que les
surprofises seraient accès dès
aujourd'hui même discours du côté de la
nuque qui ne se satisfait pas de ce
premier geste c'est une première étape
mais elle est très largement
insuffisante elle ne concerne pas
l'ensemble des
entreprises et qui ont été mis
d'ailleurs à contribution dans un
certain nombre d'autres pays européens
la nuque propose deux taxer les super
profits dans tous les secteurs de
l'économie pour les entreprises de plus
de 750 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires recettes espéré 15 à 20
milliards d'euros alors c'est pas du
tout les mêmes recettes selon qu'on fait
la taxe le maire ou la taxe nupes si je
puis me permettre David Daniel déjà sur
la proposition est-ce qu'au fond il a
pas fallu toute cette pression de la
gauche de la gauche pour en arriver
certaines taxes qui n'est pas suffisante
à vos yeux mais 200 millions d'euros
c'est déjà ça non c'est pas la pression
de la gauche qui permet aujourd'hui le
transcrire d'un projet loi de finance
c'est l'accord européen et nous depuis
le mois de juillet on est partisan de
cette approche européenne en matière de
fiscalité d'ailleurs beaucoup ironisait
il y a trois mois en disant que quand on
ne voulait pas faire quelque chose on le
renvoyait à l'Europe que l'Europe
n'avancerait jamais qu'il ne se
passerait jamais rien compris c'est une
contribution exceptionnelle à 27 dont on
décide finalement de transcrire les
contours en participants sont votes au
niveau de Bruxelles c'est exactement ça
et d'ailleurs les recettes sont plus
importantes que ce qui apparaissait dans
le reportage puisque il est vrai que
c'est 200 millions d'euros pour la
partie pétrolière celle qui concerne
totale mais c'est de l'ordre de 6 à 7
milliards d'euros Bruno Le Maire l'a
d'ailleurs annoncé dans la même
interview pour l'ensemble du producteur
d'énergie puisque d'autres mesures c'est
de capter toutes les rentes du secteur
de l'énergie qui aujourd'hui ne sont
effectivement pas dû à l'innovation
de l'énergie et transports de containers
pourquoi vous mettez pas la CMA-CGM qui
a fait des supers profits plus 214% sur
le dernier semestre 14,8 milliards
d'euros c'est ce que réclame les
républicains c'est possible non le
transport maritime c'est différent il ne
profite pas de la crise de l'énergie il
paye plus cher la crise de l'énergie
puisqu'il paye le carburant pour leur
bateau c'est ma CGM bénéficient du fait
que pendant l'année qui vient de
s'écouler il y a une reprise très forte
du commerce international qui fait que
le prix du fret a augmenté mais ça nous
renvoie une question beaucoup plus large
qui est effectivement de savoir si on
considère que tout augmentation de
profit et illégitime et doit être
capturé par l'état où est-ce qu'on
considère comme c'est le cas pour nous
qui est une différence entre des rentes
qui sont liées à la crise de l'énergie
qu'il faut capter et des profits qui
peuvent être liés à un ensemble de
choses à une stratégie de marché
l'innovation un redressement
d'entreprise un effet positif et
temporaire de certains marchés et qui
concourent pour le coup à la bonne santé
notre économie c'est cette différence-là
que nous faisons c'est cette différence
d'ailleurs qui est faite par l'Europe et
qui est faite par la quasi-totalité des
pays européens
dispositif européen c'est une bonne
première étape j'observe que c'est déjà
un changement de pied pour le
gouvernement contrairement à ce que vous
dites d'ailleurs à l'instant je rappelle
que au tout début du mois de septembre
Bruno Le Maire disait les super profits
c'est parce que c'est il y en a pas
maintenant il propose de mon point de
vue de manière très insuffisante mais de
transcrire dans le droit français un
accord européen qui considère bien qu'il
existe des profits exceptionnels puisque
il vise à les mettre à contribution en
même temps manuel montpargot vous
défendez un dispositif qui fait des
milliards de recettes et on comprend pas
la loi fiscale française c'est la même
dans tous les pays on peut pas taxer des
bénéfices faits à l'étranger les
bénéfices de total ils sont pas sur le
raffinage qui est certes qui repart il
se fait dans les pays producteurs de
pétrole sur cette question mais d'abord
je veux préciser les choses la
proposition que nous avons formulée de
taxes sur les super profits qui
concernent l'ensemble des entreprises
qui ont réalisé cette année un chiffre
d'affaires super à 750 millions d'euros
et qui ont réalisé cette année des
profits de 25% supérieurs à la moyenne
réalisée entre 2017 et 2019 elle ne
concerne que les profits réalisés en
France et son chiffrage estimé est
compris entre 10 et 20 milliards d'euros
pour l'année 2022 par contre divergence
mais je l'assume c'est qu'elle concerne
l'ensemble des secteurs de l'économie
pas parce que un profit serait par
nature problématique mais parce que un
super profit parce qu'on parle de 25%
par de plus par rapport à une période de
référence et on ne taxe que le surplus
c'est de mon point de vue dans la
période que nous sommes en train de
vivre un profit qui doit être pour
partir pas en entier partager
interface à la situation difficile qu'on
connaît on traverse de multiples crises
la crise de l'énergie et sans doute la
plus la plus difficile pour les Français
c'est du symbole aussi la politique
quand vous voyez ces chiffres-là qui
donnent le tournis vous dites pas vous
et lui de la nation il faut qu'on fasse
un geste tout simplement un geste et
c'est très important que tout le monde
contribue vous avez tout à fait raison
de le dire d'ailleurs si on regarde la
crise de l'énergie l'État et les
collectivités locales contribuent très
fortement avec le bouclier tarifaire
avec un ensemble de mesures en payant
d'ailleurs assez cher les factures
d'énergie je pense aux collectivité
locale les entreprises qui consomment de
l'énergie payent aussi des facturer
évidemment les particuliers les ménages
font des efforts considérables et donc
il est normal que les producteurs
d'énergie prennent aussi leur part ils
soient mises à contribution et là-dessus
manuel Bompard a d'ailleurs très bien
rappelé à l'instant ce n'est pas
là-dessus qu'il y a une divergence entre
la nupesse et nous et d'ailleurs j'en
profite mais c'est ce que Manuel Bompard
vient aussi d'expliquer la proposition
de la nupes ne permettrait pas de taxer
davantage total que la proposition que
nous venons en revanche que propose ce
que vous proposez dans le référendum
d'initiative partagée voilà mais pas
dans la deuxième page totale c'est le
texte toutes les grandes entreprises qui
ont une augmentation de profit que vous
jugez excessive pour notre part nous
considérons nous considérons qu'il est
très important de mettre tout le monde à
contribution dans la crise et ce sera le
cas avec notre mesure en revanche il est
très important de ne pas rajouter à la
crise énergétique une crise économique
et je crois que c'est ça
j'ai une autre proposition pour payer
d'amende pour faire payer davantage
total et vous la connaissez c'est
d'asseoir une taxe sur les ventes
réalisées en France et dans ce cas là
vous savez très bien que Total serait
davantage ça tombe bien vous je vais y
répondre dans le débat budgétaire
évidemment sur LCP on va suivre ça de
très très près vous êtes évidemment tous
les deux à nouveau bienvenue le cas
échéant on va présente ouvrir une page
spéciale consacrée à Simone Veil il y a
Simone le voyage du siècle sort en salle
aujourd'hui c'est un film important qui
montre combien tous les combats de
Simone Veil sont plus que jamais
d'actualité la comédienne Elsa
Zilberstein qui incarne Simone Veil à
l'écran il est exceptionnel vous allez
le voir elle nous rejoint dans un
instant avec le réalisateur Olivier
Dahan mais aussi avec Jean-Louis Debré
et Aurore berger on les accueille tous
ensemble juste après l'invitation signée
ce soir elles amont d'agaba
si on vous invite Elsa Zilberstein et
Olivier Dahan c'est parce que vous avez
décidé de raconter une figure du XXe
siècle une histoire française un destin
hors du commun pour vous Simone Weil
méritait un grand film alors elles
aiment gilberstein pour un carnet cette
icône vous avez travaillé sa voix ici à
l'Assemblée nationale la voix de Simone
Weil c'est celle qui a défendu le droit
l'avortement la parole est à Madame le
Ministre de la Santé je voudrais tout
d'abord vous faire partager une
conviction de femmes je m'excuse de le
faire devant cette assemblée presque
exclusivement composée d'hommes
aucune femme ne recourt de gaieté de
coeur à l'avortement il suffit d'écouter
les femmes nous voulons mettre fin à
l'avortement clandestin une voix de
femme façade des hommes parfois très
hostiles certains n'hésitant pas à
comparer l'avortement aux chambres à gaz
barbarie organisée comme elle le fut
hélas il y a 30 ans par le nazisme en
Allemagne que peut-il y avoir à ce
moment-là dans la tête de celle qui a
survécu à l'horreur des camps de
concentration
publiquement elle n'a alors jamais
évoqué son passé elle le fait lors de
l'inauguration d'un hôpital presque
malgré elle
[Musique]
la France apprend que Simone Veil est
une rescapée un passé que la femme
politique évoque avec force en 1979
quand le Front national perturbe un de
ses meetings
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une furie très survécu à pire que
vous m'être bordel faut partir j'arrête
pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Simone Veil consacrera sa vie à
témoigner témoigner pour ne jamais
oublier l'horreur de la Shoah
[Musique]
bonsoir Elsa dit Berstein et merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ici à l'Assemblée nationale
là où d'ailleurs vous avez tous les deux
tourner une partie du film dans
l'hémicycle du Palais Bourbon et là où
Simone Veil est entré dans l'histoire
bonsoir Olivier Dahan merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation pour ce
beau film dont vous êtes le réalisateur
on va revenir avec vous sur le débat sur
l'IVG de 1974 75 qui a été d'une
violence inouïe dans l'hémicycle et la
manière dont vous le mettez en scène
bonsoir Jean-Louis Debré vous êtes un
peu chez vous ici on est ravi de vous
retrouver ancien président de
l'Assemblée nationale merci d'avoir
accepté d'évoquer Simone Veil que vous
avez rencontré tout jeune vous allez
nous raconter d'ailleurs vous en parler
Simone Veil est une des femmes qui ont
réveillé la France dans votre livre chez
Faya et d'ailleurs dans votre spectacle
qui je crois cartonne dans les seuls les
meilleures scènes de France c'est j'ose
dire enfin bonsoir berger présidente du
groupe Renaissance il y a des députés à
l'assemblé pour qui Simone Veil est un
modèle qui est même la source de
l'engagement en politique et je crois
que c'est votre cas on va en parler avec
vous et vous avez d'une certaine façon
envie de continuer son combat avec une
proposition de loi Elsa et le Bersheim
c'est un projet que vous portez depuis
des années vous êtes à l'initiative de
ce film pourquoi c'était si fondamental
et presque envie de dire si viscéral
pour vous d'incarner Simone Veil au
cinéma déjà parfois des fois on explique
pas toujours les choses de manière
concrète et précise je crois que c'est
la rencontre avec elle qui m'a
transformer
ému et
chamboulé vraiment j'ai eu la chance de
la rencontrer plusieurs fois et au fil
de nos rencontres je me suis dit assez
vite il faut un grand film sur cette
femme peut-être parce que ce modèle de
résilience de puissance
[Musique]
d'incandescence de vibrants de
vibrations et ce modèle de survie
me fascinait et je me suis dit elle est
la France elle est elle est la France en
fait elle représente un tel modèle de
courage
inexplicable aussi c'est tout ce qu'elle
était après je me suis plongé dans une
vie et je me suis dit mon dieu c'est
c'est la petite histoire dans la grande
histoire elle parle d'elle qui vient de
l'horreur qui vient de l'enfer de de
l'ignoble pour aller vers la lumière et
pour et pour transformer finalement
sa survie et transformer tout ce qu'elle
a vécu en fait je disais que c'était un
film important parce que il va sortir
quasiment au moment où les derniers
survivants de la Shoah
et elle dit vous vous dites
j’étais et plus personne ne pourra dire
j'y étais et plus personne ne pourra
dire voilà ce qui fut c'est aussi pour
ça qu'il fallait le faire pour
transmettre cette mémoire oui c'est un
film aussi se faire sur la mémoire
d'ailleurs
sur notre passé notre avenir comment on
transforme le passé comment qu'est-ce
qu'on apprend du passé ou pas c'est
c'est au travers elle qu'on parle du
siècle donc je crois que c'était aussi
peut-être par rapport à ma famille
inconsciemment j'avais envie de
personnel aussi oui mais pas que en fait
c'est je pense c'est assez impalpable
pourquoi on a envie en tout cas je
pensais que c'était une femme hors du
commun peut-être pour la transmission
quand même et pour tous ces combats et
de me dire c'est une femme hors du
commun qui s'est battue aussi pour la
dignité des êtres contre les injustices
et sa manière la manière qu'elle a eu de
se battre sans être une femme politique
pur jus
accrocher à son petit pouvoir mais une
femme hors norme qui s'est toujours
battue pour les autres et pour le
respect des droits de l'homme et ça
c'est une dimension assez importante je
vous dirai d'ailleurs comment on se
prépare un rôle pareil puisque c'est pas
si c'est évident Olivier Dahan il y a un
peu un fil rouge quand même dans le film
c'est que cette parole des survivants au
fond elle hante Simone Veil
systématiquement cette histoire lui est
ramené est-ce que c'est aussi parce que
après guerre la parole n'était pas
possible elle était tabouillée il
voulait parler les survivants et on les
assignait au silence et on voit ça dans
le film pratiquement tout du long j'ai
voulu montrer ça effectivement dans le
film quelque chose qu'on voit un peu
souvent en fait qui était la chape de
plomb qui s'est battu sur les sur les
ceux qui sont revenus et qui étaient en
gros ne pas parler en fait tout
simplement parce que l'État était avancé
et pas revenir même sur le passé très
très récent et donc pas une interdiction
mais la société a fait que vous n'avez
pas le droit de parler non effectivement
les Français ne pouvaient pas entendre
en tout cas pas tout de suite et donc
les gens se sont conformés à ça en fait
plus ou moins en fait alors c'est un
film qui est un peu mosaïque c'est pas
du tout un biopic classique puisque
c'est à la faveur de l'écriture de ces
mémoires que Simone Veil revit des
moments des flashbacks fondateurs de sa
vie on est à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
impossible de pas évoquer c'est une
salinaugurale tout de suite on est 1974
début 75 et puis à ce débat alors là
racontez-nous parce que c'est d'une
violence mais d'une violence inouï d'une
certaine façon les camps la rattrape à
ce moment-là dans l'émission j'ai juste
pris tous les relevés officiels et il
n'y avait que malgré tout à apprendre
c'est quasiment Verbatim toutes les
attaques bien sûr il y a le texte que
fait que dit Elsa en Simone qui veille
qui qui dit le texte effectivement où
elle porte chance
des députés
un an que quand je me documentais
beaucoup pour écrire ben j'ai lu
effectivement c'était hallucinant
c'était de c'était d'une violence
extrême c'était tous les cousons de
permis et c'était c'était comment dire
par exemple
dans l'hémicycle avec cette loi il y a
une phrase qui est lancée si les
embryons sont à vos yeux désagresseurs
et bien ses agresseurs vous accepterez
madame qu'il soit jeté au four
crématoire voilà Aurore berger ce qu'on
disait il y a quoi une cinquantaine
d'années c'est qu'est-ce que je raconte
non il y a 20 oui 40 oui une
cinquantaine d'années un peu moins de 50
ans j'ai eu la chance de voir le film et
j'étais très frappé à la fois par la
pudeur avec laquelle son histoire est
racontée et aussi à quel point on la
redécouvre parce qu'en fait on a tous
une image un peu de Simone Veil on a
tous un morceau de sa vie qui nous
touche ou qui nous parle
singulièrement que notre et revoir son
parcours de magistrate par exemple ma
particulièrement frappée et à quel point
ça fait écho aussi par rapport à ce
qu'on vit ce qui est certain c'est que
on parle beaucoup depuis cet été des
débats qui sont des débats agités qui
peuvent être violents à l'Assemblée
nationale quand on est au cœur de
l'hémicycle on ressent cette emprise
physique c'est sans commune mesure avec
ce qu'elle a subi avec ce qu'elle a
trouvé
parce qu'en fait c'est ça qui est frappé
neuf femmes à l'Assemblée contre 480
hommes et c'est vrai que la violence
qu'on ne regardait avec Olivier ce qu'on
lui a dit on l'a réduite à son rang de
femme et de déporter et on lui en a fout
plein la gueule et la force avec
laquelle elle s'est relevée et qu'elle a
vaincu grâce d'ailleurs à Antoine Weil
qui a été merveilleux et qu'il l'a aidé
avec l'audius petit et la Ferrand il a
renversé
quanto jamais a fait aussi par derrière
c'était assez hallucinant mais c'est
vrai que c'est étonnant de voir la
violence je sais pas comment c'est
aujourd'hui on connaît tous cette photo
où elle a ses mains plongée
et en fait pas du tout elle est juste
fatiguée il faut pas trop généraliser
car il faut jamais oublier que la loi a
été votée par de 1804 voies contre 189
après des débats d'une violence mais on
était habitués à l'Assemblée nationale
et à la Chambre des députés avant à ses
débats et violence reprenait tous les
débats donc ce qui est très important
c'est qu'il y a pas une Simone Veil il y
a plusieurs six bonnes veilles il y a
d'abord cette femme qui avait courage
avec détermination avec dignité à
incarner la déportation des Juifs de
France à un moment où on en parlait pas
oui il fallait allons parler ou c'était
tabou
et là elle a mené un combat pour
l'histoire et pour l'avenir combat pour
l'histoire pour qu'on oublie pas ce qui
s'est passé mais pour que l'avenir
n'oublie pas cette histoire vous-même
vous l'avez rencontré très très jeune
vous connaissiez la famille d'Antoine
les poux de Suède
et puis je me suis première fois que
j'ai rencontré je devais avoir 14-15 ans
elle m'a dit qu'est-ce que tu veux faire
et je dis je veux devenir magistrat
parce que je suis venu et mais c'est
très bien moi aussi je suis magistrat et
c'est le premier mot que j'ai entendu et
après ce qui serait frappant dans cette
femme quand on regarde notre histoire il
y a très peu de personnages qui émergent
30 ans ou 40 ans après ils sont partent
dans l'oubli du temps sauf une femme qui
est la deuxième femme en France ça va
être ministre à temps plein à plein
exercice après Madeleine chapeau point
pinceau s'appuie soit 4e avant on avait
des secrétaire d'État c'est la première
fois et cette femme qu'on connait
uniquement parce qu'elle a incarné cette
déportation tout d'un coup elle va
forcer l'admiration de ses adversaires
et de ses amis je reprends la phrase
parce que avec courage sans
ultrances
avec
ma 113 humaine elle a fait passer cette
loi à l'Assemblée puis au Sénat et puis
un troisième personnage parce que cette
femme qui a vécu la guerre comme
personne ne peut l'avoir vécu sauf des
familles elle va en tant que présidente
du Parlement européen
œuvré pour la réconciliation
la femme en fait elle est féministe elle
est féministe sans avoir été MLF sans
forcément être de gauche il y a un
personnage très important dans le film
c'est la mère de de Simone Yvonne
à qui elle doit tout en fait elle doit
se cette volonté farouche de s'émanciper
de travailler d'être indépendante elle
lui fait découvrir Louise Weiss ça s'est
formidable pour tous ceux qui
connaissent pas qui vont découvrir
c'était qui cette Simone qu'on voit ici
sa mère une femme extrêmement importante
pour elle elle a toujours l'impression
que sa mère est plutôt les rendre plus
douce plus compréhensive qu'elle et
d'ailleurs Marceline Loridant et parle
beaucoup de la mère de Simone quand
elles sont à birkena elle dit qu'elle
était tellement rassembleuse généreuse
merveilleuse Simone avait toujours
l'impression que sa mère était mieux
qu'elle et quand elle perd sa mère dans
les camps voilà c'est sa blessure elle
ne s'en remet jamais non seulement la
blessure des camps comme elle disent les
filles les filles de birkana au resta
birkana elles sont comme mortes une
partie d'elle qui est morte mais cette
mère qui lui a transmis le goût de
l'effort du travail lui disant moi j'ai
pas pu faire ce que je voulais j'ai pas
pu faire mes études enfin devenir
chimiste ou biologiste donc toi il
faudra que tu te battes et que tu te
travailles pour être indépendantes et
elle lui a transmis ça très jeune alors
que c'est c'était une époque où les
femmes travaillaient pas donc c'était
vraiment d'une modernité hallucinante et
c'est vrai que cette mère est fondatrice
et et
à 97 ans sa secrétaire me disait qu'elle
toujours de moments à 87 ans encore
ouais il y a une scène très forte
d'ailleurs qui qui raconte comment la
première fois elle parle des camps dans
une interview rester célèbre et elle dit
au fond je vais peut-être plus dur que
ma mère et ma sœur qui n'ont pas pu
résisté il y a une intégrité morale très
très forte aussi de Simone Veil
illustration quand elle est ministre de
la Santé confrontée au 1er malade du
sida regardez
donc comment ça va se passer alors je
vous explique la rédaction du journal
veut commencer le 20H directement sur
l'image de cette porte vous serez déjà à
l'intérieur prétendument en train de
parler à un malade du sida on vous
donnera un signal vous sortirez et vous
pourrez donner votre discours en direct
et après on lancera les titres et je
comprends pas bien en fait donc vous
êtes en train de me dire qu'il n'y aura
pas de malade dans la chambre non
je veux pouvoir parler avec un vrai
malade dans une vraie chambre on entend
20 minutes avant mon intervention et
être en tête avec lui est-ce que c'est
clair on ne mentira pas niveau ni moi
j'ai pas fini c'est pour sortir d'une
chambre vide on pensait que pour votre
confort il était préférable mais je m'en
fiche de mon confort
je préfère être dans l'inconfort que
dans le mensonge est-ce que c'est clair
on va trouver une solution attendez je
vous en prie
voilà il y a tous ces mauvaises dans
cette scène je préfère la confort que
d'être dans le mensonge elle peut être
dure aussi elle était je pense qu'il
fallait qu'elle soit dur je pense qu'il
faut être dur je pense en réalité quand
on s'oppose comme ça d'une manière enfin
comment dire en tant que femme en tant
que politique aussi il y a un moment
donné pour faire passer ses idées
j'imagine qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
être dur et en même temps elle était
quand même nourri d'une grande grande
humanité également mais simplement la
carapace c'était je pense très épaisse
effectivement Jean-Louis Debré c'est
vrai que souvent on entendait les
politiques dire oh là là Simone Veil
elle a eu elle a eu comme grand allié
Jacques Chirac qui lui a mis
ministre et en même temps ils ont pas
toujours été alliés en politique vous
savez on n'est jamais très longtemps
amis ou très longtemps adversaire mais
c'est pas ça mais le souvenir que j'ai
dans ma dans ma tête de Simone Veil
c'est une femme
extrêmement digne et on a le sentiment
qu'elle porte en elle une souffrance
qui ne peut pas s'effacer et elle ne
peut pas s'effacer et dans son action
contre le sida dans son action contre
les conditions d'hébergement des détenus
il y a un mot qui revient
ce sont des êtres humains et elle qui a
vu la mort vu la mort de sa famille qui
a vu le noir arriver
il y a un espèce de sursaut même si ils
sont pas bien ce sont des êtres humains
qui ont le droit au regard et à une
certaine compassion
en fait ce qui est troublant et
magnifique et fou c'est justement
comment se départ de vie à conditionner
tous ces choix ensuite et ensuite et
cette bataille pour la dignité en disant
ce sont des êtres humains on peut pas
laisser les gens comme ça quel que leur
faute quel que soit en prison ce que les
gens ont fait je me battrai jusqu'au
bout quand elle va en Yougoslavie et
qu'elle parle pour la Yougoslavie et
qu'elle dit qu'est-ce qui se passe que
fait la Croix-Rouge en fait il y a une
bataille profonde quelqu'un me racontait
une anecdote je crois que c'était Blasi
quand je l'ai interrogé un jour il dit
mais il me raconte on lui raconte ce qui
se passe à Sarajevo elle dit je pars
tout de suite ils ont pris un avion le
soir même ils sont allés donc c'est
quelqu'un qui s'indigne et ça c'est un
dignation elle est essentielle et avec
Odace et sans peur elle va pour en tout
cas regarder les gens avec une empathie
et une et un regard qui lui est propre
je trouve berger même si ça va à
l'encontre d'une idée admise parce que
quand elle va je me souviens s'élever
contre la condition des détenus en
qu'est-ce qu'on dit également on les
prisons ces trois étoiles non attention
ce sont des êtres humains et peut-être
demain a le droit à être regardé être
entendu quel que soit les fautes qu'il a
commises
cette passion pour au fond de l'être
humain la capacité à s'indigner on parle
beaucoup d'indignations aujourd'hui dans
notre époque est-ce que c'est la même je
pense qu'on a peut-être une indignation
qui est parfois plus facile que les
combats qu'elle a pu mener parce que
l'indignation n'était pas facile quand
il s'agissait de dénoncer les conditions
carcérales à l'époque quand il
s'agissait de monter à la tribune pour
justement les droits humains avec ce fil
rouge tendu en permanence sur la
question de la dignité humaine quand on
parle aujourd'hui de la question des
droits des femmes vous voyez bien que
malheureusement parfois on en parle pas
justement sous ce prisme là de la
capacité à se dire qu'en fait c'est un
continuum sur la manière avec laquelle
les droits humains doivent être
appréhendés dans une société et je pense
que elle elle avait cette force là de
Constance en fait il y a un moment il y
a rien qui se casse dans son parcours
tout est lié tout est co
mes chers collègues mesdames messieurs
c'est un très grand honneur que vous
m'avez fait en appelant à la présidence
du Parlement européen aussi
[Musique]
l'émotion qui est la mienne en prenant
place à ce fauteuil
est-elle plus profonde que je ne serai
l'exprimer
j'ai exprimé la gratitude que nous
devons avoir à l'égard de Louise Weiss
car si bien guidé nos premiers pas vous
me permettrez d'y revenir d'un mot sans
vous formaliser que je cite la
paris-minante qu'à la prise dans toutes
les luttes menées pour l'émancipation
des femmes
est une grande espérance parce qu'elle
est le bastion de la démocratie et de la
liberté
comment ne pas être conscient de la
nécessité de nous unir pour nos épaules
et les uns les autres
et résister ainsi à tout retour du
totalitarisme
Elsa liberste quand même les coups de
ses combats aujourd'hui ce qu'on disait
souvent un olivier c'est que
malheureusement le discours ouais
malheureusement tout est discours ils
auraient pu être écrit il y a deux mois
afin c'est impressionnant l'écho actuel
entre l'avortement l'Europe le
totalitariste que vous disiez c'est fou
comme le film n'est plus un film qui
parle d'une époque le film parle de nous
aujourd'hui et ça c'est assez fou et
comme si c'était un écho vous avez
réussi à incarner un rôle pareil avec le
souci aussi de dire des choses sur
aujourd'hui
ça c'est Olivier qui écrit le scénario
donc moi en l'occurrence
comment on y arrive on se prépare
comment le préparation ah ça c'est
encore autre chose c'est un long chemin
à la préparation c'est un an de
préparation qui doit partir des pieds
pour arriver dans mon corps pour que
j'arrive à l'incarner
ne plus imiter en tout cas à la voir
comme une seconde nature comme une
seconde peau essayez de que chaque jette
chaque vibration chaque regard j'ai
tellement regardé de documentaires de
documents sur l'inna Media Pro tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps je
parlais comme elle je me marchais comme
elle voilà après intégrer des mouvements
et des choses qui je voulais disparaître
enfin en étant là forcément quand tu es
actrice ou juste d'être là à 1000% pour
l'interpréter mais moi m'effacer devant
elle et la faire arriver en moi je peux
pas dire parce que c'est facile de
quitter un rôle pareil
non mais je cherche pas à le quitter en
fait j'ai elle vous accompagne il y a
des parties d'elle qui sont encore là et
puis ça part quand ça part et puis elle
m'a beaucoup donné aussi dans sa
puissance je voudrais qu'on revienne sur
ce qui se passe justement
le fond de l'air de l'époque quand on
voit aujourd'hui que les figés de Simone
Veil est tagué de croix gammée pas
seulement son portrait mais quand on
voit des étoiles jaunes revenir Aurore
berger dans les cortèges contre le pas
sanitaire ou même dans le mouvement des
gilets jaunes il y a eu aussi cette
polémique plutôt maladroite
dans le Val-d'Oise ou un parc un parc
Simone Veil a été regardé
décorer si j'ose dire et du plus mauvais
effet le panneau a été a été retiré
qu'est-ce qui se passe Aurore berger
est-ce que est-ce que ce passé qui ne
passe pas est encore là omniprésent
je crois que malheureusement il y a des
combats qui sont un peu intemporel je
pense qu'on tour de ce plateau on serait
tous heureux et satisfait de se dire que
le combat contre l'antisémitisme est un
combat qui est derrière nous comme un
certain nombre d'autres combats
évidemment je crains que malheureusement
ce ne soit pas le cas et qui faille
avoir la lucidité de le regarder en face
et de se dire que il revient que malgré
tout il revient peut-être il entretient
que certains l'entretiennent un peu tout
le monde entretien parce que c'est
quelquefois une façon de faire une sorte
de variable d'ajustement même politique
quelquefois je trouve je trouve qu'on on
se sert trop de ce sujet là aussi en
politique aussi pour pour servir
d'autres buts en fait donc et ça quelle
que soit en réalité les parties
j'entends trop souvent personnellement
parler d'antisémitisme chose comme ça de
sur les chaînes d'infos ou sur non pas
pour le combattre mais pour s'en servir
justement pour se positionner pour
pour se donner une posture quelquefois
pour le pour le pire je voudrais vous
montrer une mosaïque de dirigeants
politiques de pays dans lesquels le
droit à l'avortement est remis en cause
à différents degrés les États-Unis avec
Donald Trump puisque il est à l'origine
de la nomination des juges de la Cour
suprême qui ont interdit ou la
possibilité d'interdire à différents
états le recours à l'avortement Georgia
Meloni qui vous restreindre son accès ou
en tout cas certains de ces
parlementaires en Italie je pense aussi
à Chypre il y a de Polonais aussi mon
Rachid ou encore Victor hochban en
Russie et bien sûr il jaillir bolsonaro
est-ce qu'il est menacé ce droit dans
notre pays Aurore berger est-ce que
c'est pour ça que vous voulez le
sanctuariser je pense qu'il faut pas
considérer que c'est un acquis
inébranlable parce que ceux qui ont
considéré que c'était le cas notamment
aux États-Unis se sont réveillés en
voyant qu'en fait il y avait eu un
travail extrêmement patient extrêmement
organisé des mouvements conservateurs
qui entendu la Cour suprême à prendre
une décision d'une brutalité sans nom
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui encore une fois
on a dans ce qui est supposé être la
plus grande démocratie au monde les
États-Unis des femmes qui ne peuvent
plus avoir accès à l'avortement sauf à
prendre le risque d'année de prison des
médecins qui ne peuvent plus pratiquer
librement donc je crois que aujourd'hui
moi j'ai l'honneur d'être parlementaire
et quand on a cette responsabilité et
qu'on sait qu'on a la possibilité à un
moment de sanctuariser ce droit en
l'inscrivant dans notre Constitution je
pense qu'on a pas le droit de ne pas le
faire parce que sinon peut-être que ça
n'arrivera jamais et tant mieux si ça
n'arrive jamais mais
quelques
mots sur des avortements de des
avortements de convenance et les revenus
sur ses parents quand on dit qu'on va
des rembourser enfin on peut ne pas
vouloir pour ne pas inquiéter
délibérément ou pour se donner une image
plus respectable essayer de trouver des
chemins de traverse pour ne pas dire que
frontalement on ça craint pas l'idée
j'ai et puis derrière on voit des
incises progressifs qui sont faites qui
confortent ceux qui clairement veulent
en finir avec l'IVG et on a pour la
première fois aujourd'hui au sein de
notre émission au sein de la nationale
des députés et rassemblant national qui
ont été élus et qui disent ce qui était
dit à l'époque qui disent que l'IVG est
un génocide de masque qui parle de Shoah
donc il faut avoir ça en tête et je
pense que ça c'est notre responsabilité
de le combattre et donc de l'inscrire
dans la Constitution puisque nous on en
a l'opportunité j'ai envie Debré
à toucher à constitution ça devient
illisible il y a une déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen qui
prévoit l'égalité la dignité et la
Constitution c'est pour l'organisation
des pouvoirs publics alors si on en
revient de ces vieilles traditions où on
met tout pourquoi pas mettre
l'anti-raptisme antisémitisme et tout ce
que je veux dire c'est que
soyons forts le la lutte contre
l'avortement
le racisme la xénophobie
soir de France histoire des hommes les
uns contre les autres ce sont des
moments de de de de fièvre où on lui on
voit des phénomènes de racisme de
xénophobie d'antisémitisme la réponse
est une réponse collective c'est que on
apprenne dans les classes dans les
écoles ce que c'est que la liberté ce
que c'est que la dignité de l'homme et
que la télévision
essaye de montrer c'est parce que quel
est l'enseignement de Simone Veil c'est
une femme qui connaissait parfaitement
la conjoncture politique économique et
sociale et qui disait mon combat est un
combat pour l'histoire pour qu'on
n'oublie pas mais c'est pas c'est un
combat pour les soirs pour préparer
l'avenir or si on commence parce que
c'est trop facile les politiques on l'a
mis dans la Constitution à
débrouillez-vous mais c'est pas ça
qu'il y a un certain nombre de valeurs
qui sont des valeurs de respect de la
personne humaine de respect de la femme
et que l'avortement fait partie
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
fait partie
Aurore berger j'ai vu voilà que vous
n'en reveniez pas vous êtes sur vous
national qui je savais pas donc par
rapport à ce que vous dites quelque part
je comprends qu'elle dise il faut que ce
soit inscrit dans la constitution même
si comment regarde
la Constitution ça fixe l'organisation
il y a la déclaration le préambule et
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics la
Constitution c'est l'organisation des
pouvoirs publics
puisque Aurore berger va déposer cette
propositions
[Musique]
ils ont dit discuter de ça il y a
longtemps c'est fascinant de voir que
c'est un éternel recommencement elle
pensait de notre époque je me permets
jamais de penser de dire ce qu'elle
aurait pu penser je parle pas pour elle
après je peux dire qu'elle manque qu'une
figure comme ça justement qui est pas
accroché à son poste politique ou à ses
ambitions personnelles oui ces
indignations manquent sa présence manque
tout ce que je peux dire c'est sûr merci
beaucoup merci infiniment d'avoir
participé à ce débat Simone la traversée
d'un siècle c'est le voyage
pardonnez-moi le voyage du siècle je
voudrais signaler le livre qui a été
coordonné par le documentariste écrivain
David Teboul qui est merveilleux Simone
et ses sœurs je suis sûr que vous le
connaissez
Madeleine d'ailleurs Milou et dans le
film peut-être un mot sur elle parce que
c'est aussi elle perd sa sœur en 1952
alors qu'elle vit à Stuttgart elle est
repartie en Allemagne avec Antoine
veille et sa soeur vient la visiter et
elle repart à un accident de voiture
c'est une deuxième un deuxième drame
enfin elle a traversé
un autre enfant voilà après et un
dernier mot peut-être sur Antoine veille
parce qu'Antoine veille au départ
c'était lui qui devait être dans la
lumière c'est lui qui devait faire de la
politique Aurore berger Antoine
weillette il a essayé mais devant le
charisme devant ce courage de sa famille
il a su bien avant l'heure se mettre en
retrait
je sais pas si c'est mis en retrait
c'est à dire qu'à un moment il a fait un
choix en conscience qui était de lui
permettre à elle de réaliser ce que
peut-être lui-même n'aurait pas pu
réaliser mais elle-même n'aurait pas pu
être Simone Veil Antoine c'est Antoine
d'ailleurs c'est la demande qu'elle a
formulé et qui a été respectée au moment
de son décès c'est qu'il ne soit jamais
séparé absolument au Panthéon immortel
merci merci beaucoup vous avez compris
LCP vous recommande très très
chaleureusement d'aller voir Simone le
voyage du SEC merci beaucoup
elryderstein merci Olivier d'avant
Aurore berger Jean-Louis Debré très
belle soirée sur LCP à demain
[Musique]